if you frequent the internet you have
likely seen memes in videos with a
character known as doomer
and or any of his counter characters
boomer bloomer and zoomer
if you have not these are them each of
these characters represents a distinct
personality type
usually associated with a specific
generation within current society
the doomer character is especially
popular and is what we will be focusing
on here
the doomer is an individual who is
typically in their 20s and male
although a doomer in the philosophical
sense does not need to be either
he or she does however need to be
someone who feels a sense of aimlessness
and loneliness
and is consequently stricken with a deep
despair for life for the doomer life is
meaningless and the world is inevitably
doomed by humanity's ignorance greed and
futility
as a result the doomer sees little to no
reason in engaging in traditional
pursuits
and thus retreats from society into
apathetic isolation
this character is often used in videos
and memes to illustrate various
experiences that come with this
pessimistic sense of life
things like working a dead end job
struggling to maintain or get over
romantic relationships
excessive drinking and smoking feeling
alienated from one's friends and family
etc
this character's popularity and
widespread relatability is very telling
about the conditions of the modern
person
specifically that of the current young
adult generation it reveals the depth of
pessimism and nihilism being experienced
a hopelessness for both the now and for
the future
one of the doomer's counter characters
is the boomer the name being derived
from the term baby boomer
an individual born between 1946 and 1964
two generations or so before the doomer
however the age and generation of a
boomer does not necessarily matter
what does matter is this character's
contrasting outlook on life
opposed to the doomer the boomer
possesses a positive can-do attitude
more specifically in the context of the
meme the boomer's attitude exists in a
naive
blissful ignorance of truth the boomer
chugs along in their ignorant delusion
unaware of the reality in which they
live mistakenly thinking they have it
all under control
where the doomer is aware of the world's
conditions and consequently pessimistic
about them
the boomer is unaware and thus
ignorantly blissful
unlike the baby boomers the doomer was
born in or around the 90s and grew up
through an era when technology developed
at an unprecedented rate
in an exceptionally small amount of time
the advent of the internet as well as
affordable internet devices would
completely change the way people could
experience and understand the world
during this internet generation children
and young adults had access to a
completely open and constant flow of
information
an ability to see hear talk with and
engage in the entire world
in real time all the time the world
would shrink down to fit in the palm of
one's hand
allowing one to easily see just how
absurd chaotic and meaningless
it truly is as a result a huge portion
of an entire generation would realize
early on
that things weren't all good that the
can-do positive attitude of the boomer
was outdated and ignorant of what was
really going on
with lingering counterculture narratives
from the 60s and 70s a decreasing
popularity in christianity following the
second world war
and an increasing access to information
this generation would be left with no
traditional meaning or hope to fall back
on
a generation where many find a piece of
themselves in the doomer
so now what are we doomed to exist in a
world where the options are either
blissful ignorance or informed
melancholy
in order to better understand and deal
with growing pessimistic and nihilistic
tendencies
it is helpful to refer to the work of
19th century philosophers
arthur schopenhauer and friedrich
nietzsche arthur schopenhauer is often
regarded as the philosopher of pessimism
arguably the original doomer like the
doomer's outlook for schopenhauer life
is in fact
riddled with unavoidable pain
meaninglessness and absurdity
for schopenhauer we are prisoners to our
unconscious instinct to survive
reproduce and sustain existence and in
the traditional sense
everything we do in life is merely a
product of this irrational force
void of any purpose other than to
continue to sustain itself
as a result we live a life of delusion
constantly in a frenzy
trying to impress sexual partners in
order to reproduce and trying to
accomplish things in order to find
happiness
schopenhauer writes there's only one
inborn error and that is the notion that
we exist in order to be happy
so long as we persist in this inborn
error the world seems to us full of
contradictions
for at every step in things great and
small we are bound to experience that
the world and life are certainly not
arranged for the purpose of maintaining
a happy existence
in schopenhauer's mind we want so badly
to believe that we exist to be happy
and to have specific purpose but with an
honest examination
we realize we do not this perspective
does not fall far from that of the
doomer
arguably neither the doomer nor
schopenhauer are necessarily wrong in
their assessments of life
life is in fact linked with chaos pain
and fundamental meaninglessness
the real problem however is not found in
this realization
but how this realization is handled
schopenhauer offered two solutions for
the realization
of life's meaningless suffering
asceticism and art
asceticism is the disciplined avoidance
of pleasure an overcoming of the
unconscious desire and pursuit for the
selfish immaterial
be it things like sex vanity money
social status etc
schopenhauer felt that by obtaining
control over the ceaseless yearning for
things
one can find a form of happiness in the
present moment however schopenhauer also
acknowledged the sheer difficulty in
accomplishing this feat
for it is not enough to merely realize
the senselessness of one's behaviors
in order to stop them from occurring the
level of discipline and commitment
required
would prove immensely difficult for even
the wisest of individuals
alternatively schopenhauer provided one
other solution engaging in the
aesthetics of art and philosophy as much
as possible
in this schopenhauer suggested that
things like poetry theater
music paintings literature theory etc
have the power to reveal and share truth
a truth that liberates the individual
during the moments he or she is engaging
in it
by expressing our pains and sufferings
or engaging in the expressions of others
we feel less imprisoned and less
disillusioned in our self with this
one does not need to find anything
worthwhile or ultimately meaningful in
the materialistic or traditional world
beyond the mere expression of one's
disinterest and pain within it
in expressing pain and absurdity through
arts and philosophy the pain and
absurdity is transmuted into wonder and
purpose for oneself
as well as others interestingly enough
the doomer meme itself embodies this
idea
the creation sharing and engaging of
doomer content
is an example of a doomer expressing
their sense of doom and translating it
into something
enjoyable and meaningful in an attempt
to take this idea further we will look
to the philosophy of friedrich nietzsche
a philosopher renowned for his
nihilistic take on life nihilism is the
belief in nothing
the principle that nothing has any
fundamental meaning at the end of itself
and that life
is and will always involve a suffering
through this meaninglessness
during his life in the 19th century
nietzsche found that traditional
religion
ceased to help the modern person in
dealing with the pains of life
and that nihilism was the only rational
and practical approach that remained
however for nietzsche the
meaninglessness found in nihilism did
not suggest that we should give up and
retreat into a dull apathetic life
rather the realization that life is
meaningless permits the individual to
look inside him or herself and create
their own meaning and self-identity
the world is full of systems and
pressures to conform to the collective
religions traditions and mass movements
that attempt to lead us in certain
arbitrary directions
the individual nature rights has always
had to struggle to keep from being
overwhelmed by the tribe
if you try it you will be lonely often
and sometimes frightened
but no price is too high to pay for the
privilege of owning yourself
the pressure of accepting mass
methodologies and principles in life is
has and will always be immense the
resistance of such comes with feelings
of alienation and hardship
however for nietzsche the pain of caving
in is infinitely worse
in the context of modern times perhaps
the doomer feels a heightened alienation
from the world because the internet
compounds the weight of social pressure
and a sense of detachment
however this experience of alienation
and despair is not unnatural nor without
value
rather one must walk deliberately
through the mud of life realizing that
there will be ongoing pains and
challenges in their self-actualization
and instead of turning away from them
lean into them and face the sufferings
head-on
developing themselves and their personal
meaning no matter how uncommon or hard
it may be
nietzsche felt that the key to suffering
is knowing how to use suffering
i assess the power of a will by how much
resistance pain torture it endures and
knows how to turn to its advantage
nature rides by inviting suffering in
and recognizing it as an opportunity to
develop wisdom
and resilience we utilize it as a method
of creating our own purpose
and greatness in the fundamental pain
and meaninglessness of life we must not
find ourselves with an indifference that
renders us lethargic and paralyzed away
from caring about anything but rather an
indifference that inspires us to create
meaning
and care for things we deem enjoyable
and engaging
for both nietzsche and schopenhauer the
greatest reason for life is found in the
self-realization
and self-expression of one's unique
truth the utilization of the suffering
and chaos in life and turning it into
wonder wisdom and greatness
with this in mind if we square away our
life as best we can
accepting the inevitable chaos and
suffering if we obtain the money we can
want and need to sustain our life
attempting to keep a close eye on our
unconscious irrational desires
and if we live with an interest to
create personal meaning and engage in
expressive activities
then we can build a life worth living
even in the face of apparent chaos doom
or futility this attitude can be found
in the hopeful doomer character
bloomer a character who in the meme
possesses the awareness of the sad and
painful realities of life
but still sees that there can be purpose
to it all still sees that there is an
opportunity for meaning and wonder to be
created and experienced and that however
messy the world may be
it is still worth playing in and trying
to make the most of
you